le barrage cassé et le nouveau barrage là-bas d'
accord quand nous arrivons ici il suffit de tourner
à droite et de survoler la nouvelle
année
beaucoup vous savez euh
énorme quantité de sable
mais nous devons
je pense que nous devons tirer sur le barrage
ici nous  Je dois abattre ça ici et
nous devons faire un tu sais qu'un général qui
va
comme nous le faisons maintenant
n'est
pas si fort
là-bas
et maintenant vous avez toutes les structures en
bas, d'
accord,
tout ce que je peux faire, c'est aller jusqu'à 500 mètres et
faisons juste un downshot
essayons de voir pour
remonter et voir ce que nous pouvons voir de ce
côté vous avez le soleil dans votre
caméra
arrêtez d'enregistrer
assis ici
hein
peter vous filmez oui d'
accord
je
traverse
c'est mieux les
europes étaient aussi  beaucoup vous savez sur le
côté
ce que nous disons que ces
maisons petites tentes maintenant c'est la
rubrique ils vont retourner au toit rouge
ouais d'
accord c'est bien
oui d'
accord